Você acorda com aquele peso no corpo,
músculos que parecem estarem te traindo,
um cansaço que nem 8 horas de sono
resolve e de vez em quando aquele
formigamente esquisito que desce pela
perna. Bateu no médico, exames normais,
tomou relaxante muscular, não deu em
nada. E aí você fica naquele limbo,
achando que o problema é psicológico ou
que você tá ficando velho antes do
tempo. Mas eu vou te dizer uma coisa nos
próximos minutos. Tem uma deficiência
nutricional silenciosa que afeta a
metade da população que os exames
convencionais não conseguem enxergar e
que pode estar por trás desses três
sintomas. E o pior não é nem isso. O
pior é que ignorar pode estar destruindo
suas mitocôndrias, acelerando o seu
envelhecimento celular e te empurrando
direto pra resistência insulínica. Fica
comigo que isso vai mudar a forma como
você entende seu próprio corpo.
Olha só, eu atendo no consultório
pacientes que chegam com essa tríade,
dor muscular, fadiga profunda e
formigamento.
E a história é sempre parecida. Já
rodaram por vários médicos, fizeram
hemograma, glicemia, tireoide, tudo
aparentemente normal. Aí o médico olha
pra cara deles e fala: "Você precisa se
exercitar mais, tomar antidepressivo,
relaxar, mas sabe que ninguém investiga
o magnésio intracelular". E por que não?
Porque a medicina convencional ortodoxa
ainda olha pro exame de magnésio sérico
do sangue, aquele de sangue comum, e
acha que tá tudo resolvido. Só que tem
um problemão nisso aí. Um estudo
publicado em 2018 na revista Nutrients
deixou bem claro: Apenas 0,3%
do magnésio do corpo está no soro
sanguíneo. Isso mesmo, menos de 1%. O
resto 60% nos ossos, 27% nos músculos,
19% nos tecidos moles. Então, quando
você faz aquele exame de magnésio comum,
você tá olhando só para 0,3%
da história toda. É como olhar pro saldo
da sua conta corrente, quando todo o seu
patrimônio tá em investimentos que você
não consegue ver. O exame pode dar
normal e você está com uma deficiência
severa dentro das células.
E aqui entra um dado assustador. Estudos
recentes mostram que aproximadamente
metade da população dos Estados Unidos
consome menos magnésio do que deveria.
No Brasil, o nosso solo empobrecido em
alimentação cada vez mais
industrializada, a situação
provavelmente é parecida ou pior, mas
como ninguém mede direito, ninguém
diagnostica e o problema fica lá
silencioso fazendo estrago. Agora vamos
entrar no âmago da questão. Por que o
magnésio importa tanto? Porque ele é
cofator em mais de 600 reações
enzimáticas do corpo. 600.
Ele tá envolvido em tudo, desde síntese
de DNA, RNA até metabolismo energético.
Mas o papel mais crítico dele, que
explica aquele cansaço profundo que você
sente, é na produção de ATP dentro das
mitocôndrias. Um estudo fascinante
publicado no Scientific Reports em 2016
mostrou que quando você tem disfunção no
transporte magnésio para dentro das
mitocôndrias,
especificamente através de uma proteína
chamada MRS2,
a produção de ATP desaba. As
mitocôndrias são as usinas de energia
das suas células e elas precisam de
magnésio para funcionar direitinho. Sem
magnésio suficiente entrando nas
mitocôndrias, o ciclo de crebs, que é
onde acontece a mágica da produção de
energia, simplesmente não rola e o
resultado fadiga, que não passa com
descanso, porque o problema não é falta
de sono, é falta de energia celular. Mas
tem mais, quando as mitocôndrias não
estão funcionando bem por causa do
magnésio, por falta dele, elas começam a
produzir mais radicais livres e menos
ATP. Isso cria um estado de estresse
oxidativo crônico. E quem que sofre com
isso? Os músculos. Tecido muscular é
altamente dependente de energia. Quando
falta ATP, os músculos acumulam lactato,
aumenta a produção de metabólitos
inflamatórios e aí vem aquela dor
muscular difusa que ninguém consegue
explicar. Um artigo de 2019 no JCI em
site demonstrou algo impressionante.
Eles pegaram camundongos diabéticos,
mediram a função mitocondrial dos
cardiomiócitos
à células do músculo do coração. E o que
encontraram? Queda de 26% na produção de
ATP, aumento de 70% radicais livres
mitocondriais,
despolarização de membrana mitocondrial.
Quando suplementaram com magnésio por
seis semanas, a produção de ATP aumentou
em 80%, os radicas livres caíram e a
função mitocondrial foi restaurada. Isso
não foi em humanos, mas mostra o
mecanismo fisiológico. Muito bem. Aqui
agora entra o momento que a história
fica mais interessante.
Por que tantas pessoas têm deficiência
em magnésio? Alimentação ruim, claro,
mas tem outro fator que a maioria
ignora, resistência insulínica. E aqui
acontece um ciclo vicioso devastador. A
resistência insulínica causa perda de
magnésio pelos rins e a deficiência de
magnésio piora a resistência sulínica.
um alimenta o outro criando uma espiral
descendente. Vários estudos publicados
entre 2023 e 2024, incluindo uma revisão
abrangente do American Journal of
Kidases,
confirmaram isso. Quando você desenvolve
resistência insulina, suas células param
de responder bem à insulina. O corpo
compensa produzindo mais insulina ainda.
E essa hiperinsulinemia
crônica afeta os túbulos renais,
especificamente a reabsorção de magnésio
no ramo ascendente espesso da alça de
henle e nos túbulos destais. E qual é o
resultado? Você urina mais magnésio do
que deveria. E tem outro mecanismo, a
hiperglicemia.
Quando a glicose no sangue sobe,
especialmente depois das refeições, isso
aumenta a filtração glomerular e reduz a
reabsorção tubular de magnésio. Um
estudo mostrou correlação inversa entre
glicemia de jejum e nível de magnésio.
Quanto maior a glicose, menor o
magnésio. Agora pensa comigo. Você pode
estar anos com resistência ulínica sem
ao menos saber. Sua glicemia de jejum
pode estar perfeitamente normal, porque
glicemia de jejum parâmetro a desandar,
mas você já tá com hiperinsulinemia,
já tá com picos de glicose pós
alimentação, pós-parandial, já tá
perdendo magnésio pelos rins e suas
mitocôndrias já estão sofrendo. Aí vem o
cansaço, a dor muscular, formigamento
nas extremidades. Falando em
formigamento, esse é outro sinal
importante. pode ser deficiência de
magnésio diretamente, afetando a função
dos nervos, porque o magnésio estabiliza
as membranas dos neurônios, mas também
pode ser neuropatia periférica
incipiente causada pela resistência
sulínica e pelos picos glicêmicos. Muita
gente não sabe, mas você não precisa ser
diabético para ter neuropatia, para ter
problema nos nervos periféricos. Glicose
elevada após refeições, mesmo em pessoas
com exames normais, já é suficiente para
começar a danificar os nervos ao longo
do tempo. E tem ainda a questão das
vitaminas do complexo B, especialmente a
B12 e o folato, que trabalham junto com
o magnésio no metabolismo energético e
na proteção neurológica. Uma pesquisa de
2024 no Journal of Nutritional
Biochemistry mostrou que a deficiência
simultânea de magnésio B12 é
extremamente comum em pessoas com
síndrome metabólica e essa combinação
acelera dramaticamente o declínio
cognitivo e a neuropatia. Então, o que
fazer com essas informações? O que fazer
com tudo isso? Primeiro, aceite que o
exame de magnésio do sangue sérico comum
não é suficiente. Se for fazer o exame,
faz direito. Idealmente, você deveria
dosar o magnésio eritrocitário, que é o
magnésio dentro dos glóbulos vermelhos.
Esse exame reflete melhor os estoques
intracelulares de magnésio. Não é rotina
na maioria dos laboratórios, mas sim,
alguns laboratórios fazem. Se não
conseguir fazer esse exame, pelo menos
presta atenção nos sintomas. Segundo,
investigue resistência insulínica mesmo
que a sua glicemia de jejum esteja
normal. Peça pro médico dosar insulina
em jejum, isso é importante. Dosar junto
glicemia, dosar também as frutoosaminas
e hemoglobina glicada. Valores insulina
em jejum acima de 5 microg por ml,
aliás, 5 microunidades internacionais
por m
atenção. Embora muitos laboratórios
coloquem valores de referência muito
mais altos. O índice OMA e R, que é
calculado a partir da glicemia da
insulina de jejum, também é útil.
Valores acima de dois já indicam
resistência insulínica. Idealmente, faça
uma curva glicêmica com curva de
insulina simultânea para ver como seu
corpo responde uma carga de glicose.
Sobre suplementação de magnésio, não é
qualquer forma que funciona bem. O óxido
de magnésio, que é o mais barato, mais
vendido, tem absorção muito baixa,
geralmente só serve para soltar o
intestino. As formas mais biodisponíveis
que é bem absorvido no causa diarreia, o
treonato de magnésio, o bislicinato de
magnésio, no caso tronato de magnésio,
ele atravessa melhor a barreira
imatecefálica e é excelente paraa função
cognitiva. Temos o taurato de magnésio,
ele é interessante para quem tem
questões cardiovasculares e o dimalato
ou malato de magnésio, que ajuda
especificamente na produção de energia
mitocondrial, porque o malato é o
intermediário do ciclo de creves.
A dose terapêutica geralmente fica entre
400 e 600 mg de magnésio
elementar, 400 a 600 mg de magnésio
elementar por dia. Mas isso precisa ser
individualizado. E aqui vai um detalhe
importante. Magnésio compete com cálcio
pela absorção. Se você toma suplemento
de cálcio em doses altas, pode estar
piorando a sua deficiência em magnésio.
A proporção ideal de cálcio para
magnésio na dieta deveria ser próximo de
dois para um, dois de magnésio para um
de cálcio. Mas muita gente consome numa
proporção de cinco para um ou até 10
para um, especialmente se toma
suplementos de cálcio ou consome muito
laticínio. Além do magnésio, se há
suspeita de disfunção mitocondrial mais
ampla, outros nutrientes são
fundamentais, com enzima Q10,
especialmente na forma de biquinol, que
é mais biodisponível, el cararnitina que
transporta ácidos grassos para dentro
das mitocôndrias, ácido alfalipôico, que
é um antioxidante mitocondrial potente e
vitamina complexo B em formas ativas. Um
protocolo mitocondrial bem estruturado
geralmente inclui esses componentes
trabalhando sinergia. Mas olha,
suplemento não resolve tudo se o estilo
de vida tá destruindo as suas células. A
resistência responde extraordinariamente
bem a mudança na dieta. Reduzir
carboidratos refinados, açúcares,
aumentar proteínas de qualidade, incluir
gorduras saudáveis, fazer jantar mais
cedo para aumentar o período de jejum
noturno. Estudos de 2024 mostram que
mesmo a restrição moderada de
carboidratos, mantendo entre 100 a 150 g
por dia, já melhora significativamente a
sensibilidade à insulina em 12 semanas.
Exercício físico, especialmente
treinamento de força, é potentíssimo
para reverter resistência unica. O
músculo é o principal tecido que capta a
glicose do sangue. Então, quando você
fortalece a sua musculatura, você tá
criando um depósito maior pra glicose,
tirando pressão do pâncreas para
produzir insulina. Não precisa virar
fisiculturista, mas duas a três sessões
semanais de treino com pesos, com
resistência já fazem diferença
substancial. E o sono ele é crítico, né?
Dormir mal aumenta a resistência no dia
seguinte. É um efeito agudo imensurável.
Uma noite mal dormida já é suficiente
pro seu corpo ficar menos sensível à
insulina. E o estresse crônico,
cortisoló elevado cronicamente, promove
resistência única, aumenta a perda de
magnésio, prejudica a função
mitocondrial, está tudo interconectado.
Então, para resumir, se você tem dor
muscular que não melhora, cansaço
persistente, fumigamentos ocasionais,
não aceite um estatus normal como
resposta definitiva. Esses sintomas
podem estar te avisando sobre um
desequilíbrio metabólico, que pode ser
profundo, que se não for corrigido pode
evoluir para doenças mais sérias no
futuro. Investigue o magnésio
intracelular de verdade, não é só o
cérrico, o sanguíneo. Investigue
resistência mesmo com glicemia normal.
Considere suporte mitocondrial adequado
com magnésio de alta qualidade e outros
cofatores e fundamentalmente olhe pro
seu estilo de vida como a base de
qualquer tratamento.
A visão funcional não tá interessada em
apenas calar sintomas com medicamentos.
O objetivo é entender por aqueles
sintomas estão aparecendo e corrigir as
causas raízes. E muitas vezes essas
causas são nutricionais, são
metabólicas, são relacionadas ao estilo
de vida.
São coisas que exames convencionais não
capturam e que a consulta médica padrão
de 15 minutos não tem tempo de explorar.
Seus sintomas são mensagens, seu corpo
está tentando te dizer algo. A pergunta
é: você vai continuar silenciando essas
mensagens ou vai finalmente aprender a
linguagem que o seu corpo tá falando? E
para fechar uma verdade incômoda, o
YouTube e o próprio ambiente regulatório
me obrigam a simplificar muita coisa
aqui. Eu preciso cortar detalhes de
dose, suavizar protocolos mais avançados
e evitar combinações of label que na
prática clínica fazem diferença real.
Então, dentro da comunidade fechada, eu
não preciso colocar esse filtro. Lá eu
compartilho exatamente os protocolos que
eu uso em consultório, casos de reversão
que pareciam impossíveis se eu contasse
insoltos, combinações avançadas e
fornecedores confiáveis, além de
interpretação fina de exames e
atualizações de artigos linha por linha.
É praticamente ter acesso direto ao meu
raciocínio clínico. Temos dois níveis
nesse nosso grupo. Temos lives semanais,
materiais em PDF com dezenas de
protocolos e grupo exclusivo no
WhatsApp. Você deixa de ser um
espectador passivo e passa a fazer parte
do ciclo interno que está realmente
comprometido em dominar a medicina
funcional aplicada com profundidade, sem
superficialidade de rede social. Se isso
faz sentido para você, o botão seja
membro está aqui embaixo. Poucos têm
coragem de dar esse passo. A pergunta é:
você está entre esses poucos? Yeah.